hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and I'm sure that most of the
listeners remember back just February
2016 two and a half years ago I guess by
now when scientists announce the first
direct detection of gravitational waves
from elsewhere in the universe the LIGO
Observatory the laser interferometric
gravitational wave Observatory announced
that they had seen these signals of
black holes 30 times the mass of the Sun
spiralling into each other a billion
years ago giving off gravitational waves
and we had finally detected them they
were actually detected back in September
of 2015 and then announced in February
2016 and enormous excitement because of
this I mean it's a truly groundbreaking
discovery even though we've been
anticipating it for years and years it's
one of those things which will go down
in the textbooks and in the history
books as a real cornerstone of how we
think about the universe what is less
clear is the enormous amount of not only
work but perseverance that went in to
this discovery it's always a lot of work
to do an enormous experiment or
observation in physics or astronomy if
you discover the Higgs boson you have to
build the Large Hadron Collider and that
takes 10 billion dollars in many many
years and thousands of people working
the difference being that I don't want
to in any way disparage the people who
find found the Higgs boson I did write a
book about them and I admire them
enormous Lee but they kind of knew it
was there and how to find it right I
mean they were following a tradition of
high-energy particle physics they had to
invent new technology and so forth but
the basic path had been laid whereas
with gravitational waves there were a
lot of people who thought that there
just weren't any gravitational waves of
sufficient magnitude to be found or even
more people who thought that even if
there were we wouldn't be able to build
a detector with a sufficient sensitivity
to actually find them today's guest is
Kip Thorne who along with Ray Weiss and
Ron driver was a driving force behind
the LIGO Observatory collaboration all
the way since the 1970s and so much
effort involved not only intellectually
you know as a theorist Thorne would have
to figure out how many sources of
gravitational waves there are in the you
know
how strong they would be what they would
look like in the detector and so forth
but also you know navigating the waters
of getting funding and getting support
from the community over a course of
decades to build this enormous machine
and LIGO in particular had a history
where the first version of LIGO wasn't
really expected to see anything you know
they spent a billion dollars to build
something that they didn't expect to see
anything in the sky and they were right
they had to upgrade it to what is called
advanced LIGO before they eventually saw
something so it was really a testimony
to humankind in some sense because we
really stuck with it but there's certain
particular examples exemplars of
humankind who made it happen and Kip
Thorne is absolutely one of them of
course Kip is a very famous scientist
for many reasons he's written books he's
done enormous amounts of research in
other areas of gravitational physics
that's his expertise one of his famous
results was introducing the idea that
you can use wormholes as time machines
as long as you first find a wormhole you
might be able to travel backward in time
that was a Kip and his students who
originally came up with that idea and
this led to his second career as a movie
writer and producer Kip was also one of
the guiding forces behind the movie
interstellar so over the course of the
podcast we'll talk about LIGO of course
and gravitational waves but also quite a
bit about time travel and movie making
and things like that this is a really
good one I think you're gonna enjoy it
and before we dive in let me just remind
you that we have a patreon page if you
want to pledge a little bit of support
per episode to mine scape and because of
popular demand I've added a PayPal page
as well so if you don't like this
recurring payment kind of idea you can
just donate in one lump sum whenever you
want to it's all on the podcast web page
preposterous universe comm slash podcast
you can find the links on the right hand
side and I I greatly appreciate it
sometimes I say we greatly appreciate it
but really the whole operation is me
here in my office so thanks for keeping
the lights on here at mindscape it's
it's very very gratifying to see the
support so let's go
[Music]
kip thorne welcome to mindscape podcast
wonderful bring here I mean among your
other distinctions I'm sure that you'll
be very proud to know you are the first
Nobel Prize winner to be interviewed for
the mindscape podcast I'm not sure that
that's a honor or not you know Nobel
Prize winners who usually has bins know
that well that's not true because I was
going to say I came very close to
getting Francis Arnold on the project oh
well that would be a real coup there you
go you see like all the other Nobel
Prize winners are good so there are a
few yes yeah so you won last year not
not this year like 2018 bit was last
year right 2017 Nobel for gravitational
ways I'm sure people know the general
story but before we jump into the
physics was it mostly relief that you
felt when you finally discover the
gravitational waves or were you excited
I mean it's a long term project yeah for
me it had been a half a century right
that's consumed essentially all of my
career though as a theorist I would say
believe a lot of other things on the
side but more than half my career was
spent on it in terms of time for me when
I woke up in the morning and I had an
email from Christian not a good friend
and a member of the collaboration saying
hey go look at this such-and-such a web
site we may have at each action I went
and looked at it it was obvious it was
too good to be true it has something had
to be wrong it must been what we call a
blind injection to test the system right
this is you're faking yourself right
inviting yourself internationally
putting in fakes that's the best way to
test the system is an end-to-end test
we're a group of about something like
three or four members of the
collaboration are assigned the tests go
in electronically wiggle and mirrors in
this instrument which is chip precisely
what the gravity way it would do and
then the wiggly mirrors and signal
through the whole system all the way
through the electronics to the computer
and then through the computer to the
human beings and through the
being to the point of writing a paper
and then after the paper is written you
discover well no that was a blind
injection so we've been through that and
I figured this is a blind injection
obviously and and well it wasn't but we
weren't absolutely sure for several
months really so even you don't get told
right oh yeah so so but it gradually
became clear that this was probably the
real thing and my reaction was simply
one of profound satisfaction that I had
and that indeed put a huge fraction of
my energy of my career in the right
direction and a direction that really
paid off so there's a kind of excitement
you feel when you're told that your
experiment has found something amazing
what about the excitement you feel when
you hear you've won the Nobel Prize you
know well let me tell you about that so
it was October 3rd last year 2:15 in the
morning telephone call came in from I
think it was the Secretary General of
the Swedish Academy of Sciences I was
asleep
sound asleep woke me up though I had
been expecting it ok and I mean by the
way for the audience out there everyone
in the physics world thought the LIGO
would win the Nobel Prize
so I the at the other end he announces
himself he says it will not surprise you
we are awarding the Nobel Prize to
Rainer Weiss at MIT Barry bearish in you
at Caltech and I responded it does not
surprise me but I'm exceedingly
disappointed and he was a bit taken
aback that's not usually buddy here this
is not you do what he hears but I I said
to him this prize should have gone to
the LIGO team who pulled this off right
and not to just three people in this
case this could never have been done by
the three of us it really was a team
effort
and I thought you had learned your
lesson about this in the case of the
Nobel Prize for the Higgs boson several
years ago
where it should have gone to the team
well it went to three theorists and zero
experimenter that's right and it should
have gone to the experimenter team at
least an inmate maybe some theorists too
but yeah and so he said well we've been
discussing that but we don't do it we
don't give it a team's right and he said
but we can continue this discussion in
Stockholm in Stockholm we did continue
right and I told him in no uncertain
terms the Nobel Committee has an
obligation to educate the public about
the importance of collaborations there
there are some kinds of major scientific
breakthroughs that are going to only be
done by a big collaboration and that the
process of collaboration is absolutely
crucial for success and you're not doing
a good job of educating the public about
that and he said well yes he said I've
been sensitive to this there are a
number of members of the committee that
they're not I don't agree that our
principal goal with a Nobel Prizes two
is to educate the public about the
importance of science the value of
science what it's been done and three
individuals are better icons for science
than a big team and so that's how the
conversation went and they're still
struggling with this question about you
know I'll be honest I get that argument
I don't have strong feelings one way or
the other I think that if your goal of
the prize was to do the best possible
job honouring good science then it's
clear that the large team should win but
I mean obviously it winning it does
change the lives of the individual
winners but maybe the best public thing
that it does is bring the excitement of
science to a wider audience and and
identifying some real human faces with
that is the right way to go I really
don't know you know well that may be the
case but the breakthrough prize which is
a is only in physics but is a huge prize
I think there's some biology version so
I hate it yeah that's right I guess
you're right you're right
anyway the breakthrough prize does it in
a manner that they end with like oh they
gave two-thirds of the prize to the
collaboration right
and one-third to three individuals and I
thought that worked well yeah I mean
they give the Peace Prize to our
Croatians he surprises a mess for other
reasons but and I know other other
prizes my friend Brian Schmidt who
helped discover the accelerating
universe sort of insisted for some
prizes that rather than it be himself it
should be the team but the Nobel said no
we don't work that way yeah but it might
change I don't do you think that they're
open to changing guys through some of
them are open to change and I was told
they do have the power to change this is
not set in stone legally by no Alfred
Nobel's will yeah apparently Alfred
Nobel's will is very different than what
they actually do anyway right so do you
think overall I know the Richard Fineman
had a story or an article called Alfred
Nobel's other mistake do you think that
overall the Nobel is good for science I
think it is it's it is more effective at
reaching the broadly throughout the
world to non-scientist and giving them
some sense of the importance the power
and the beauty of science more effective
than anything else that we have yeah and
so 50 years ago what were you thinking
like what dude what was it well I guess
I want to ask you what was the opinion
about gravitational waves and so forth
but for those out there in podcast land
what is a gravitational wave a
gravitational wave can be described
heuristic ly as a ripple in the fabric
or the shape of space or of space and
time that this produced in our case by
two colliding black holes travels across
the universe bringing information about
its source the word ripple is meant to
evoke the idea of a ripple on the
surface of a pond if you throw a pebble
into the pond and it's a very quiet pond
you see the waves propagating out in
fact these waves are quite different
whereas the surface of the pond is
disturbed it goes up and down and up and
down in a way
here what happens his space is stretched
and then Scrolls and in one direction
perpendicular to the direction of the
wave is propagating and then in the
other perpendicular Direction is a
school wasn't and stretch that is it's a
stretch on one direction and squeeze on
the other and that what does it mean for
space to be stretched and squeezed we
yeah we could just think of of particles
or little tiny asteroids out there
floating in space as the wave goes by
and they're at rest with respect to each
other initially and they each ride on
the stretching and squeezing space and
so they get pushed apart and then
together apart and together so the
distance between them changes and this
is something where people had talked
about it for a long time
Einstein had it sort of went back and
forth as I recall right like he his
opinion about was about these were even
a real thing changed over time it did
there were times when he lost faith in
gravitational waves and very quickly
however he recovered and realized well
the other they ought to be real but it
was controversial among theorists who
worked in relativity theory at least
among some fraction of the community all
right all the way up into the 1980s and
so really quite surprising it took so
long for the community to totally sort
this out and what was the what's so
difficult about figuring it out the
difficulty is you have a theory that's a
mathematical theory and it's a question
of truly understanding the physical
consequences of the mathematics and to
me it was obvious but you know I was of
the younger generation so I was taught
in what I would call the right way by my
mentor John wheeler to think about it
but to people of an earlier generation
who struggled to understand the
mathematics it it was not totally clear
until after we started to build planning
these gravitational wave detectors
wasn't their famous thought experiment
by fine men that was trying to show that
ya know these were physically real
that's right and so that's one of the
compare
in which he said let's take a stick and
we'll put some beads on the stick and
there's a little bit of friction between
the beads and the stick and when the
gravitational waves go by they move the
beads back and forth because they can
slide the stick is stiff and it resists
being stretched and squeezed so it
doesn't move hardly at all because of
its resistance the beads don't resist so
the beads go back and forth and they
wrap on the stick they heat the stick up
and if you have a strongly enough ways
they might even start a fire I just
loved that example for so many reasons I
mean everyone else is sitting there with
equations trying to figure out what the
symmetries are and what's going on and
he has this stick Nadine is relying on a
particular equation called the equation
of geodesic deviation it would say
another physicist
mathematical physicist Felix Mirani who
first said hey this is the equation we
should be using to discuss gravitational
waves that was so so fineman's remarked
about this was at a conference in Chapel
Hill North Carolina
1956 or sinks 57 57 okay and might have
been 56 it was anyway Felix Pirani was
almost that same time just within a year
or so that same time so and the people
hadn't identified really the right way
mathematically to discuss waves and tell
them and and it was Fineman hoof as far
as i'm aware who first gave this
beautiful description but it did come
from the mathematics and that's a that's
a remark about firemen exactly of course
was a close friend of mine
yeah Fineman would at conferences like
this he would come up with some really
remarkable statement that would startle
people and this was not the only one and
if you would then afterwards ask fine
where did this come from where did you
get this sudden insight he would say
well I did some long calculations
several years ago I was just trying to
understand how things work and once I
understood
I was satisfied I didn't need to write a
paper describing this I just understood
and I was satisfied just wait to the
right moment at the conference to pull
it out right right no Betty he was
driven by his own personal curiosity
yeah and and he had an enormous
storehouse of information that came from
the curiosity driven questions he had
asked to himself over the decades I know
about this among other things that this
famous conference in Chapel Hill did is
it helped launch the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics on
wheeler was Hugh Everett's advisor and
Richard Feynman's advisor and your
adviser so and John Wheeler who promoted
this didn't believe it he didn't believe
it no that's right yeah that's a
separate story that's another podcast so
there was skepticism about gravitational
waves there was arguably even more
skepticism about black holes today
indeed and for the same reason the issue
of really understanding what the
mathematics were saying was even harder
in the case of black holes than
gravitational waves and so that's got to
sysm also well that lasted I think up
until the early 1970s when it was
finally laid to rest and that's about
the time you started thinking about like
Oh or gravitational even more generally
is that's about the time I started
thinking about the experiments so I was
thinking about theory of gravitational
waves beginning in the mid-60s when I
was John Wheeler student and just
finishing working with him it was after
Joseph Webber in 69 had announced
tentative evidence for gravitational
waves that I really began thinking
deeply about it fairly deeply as I could
about experiments so although I had been
a a champion enthusiast of Webber
earlier it was really only triggered by
that and it was 1972 that I wrote with
bill press say a student of mine at the
time a the first my first paper about a
vision for what you can do with
gravitational waves if you could detect
them and it was that same year that
Rainer Weiss array as I called him at
MIT he wrote a marvelous technical paper
where he
described his invention of the kind of
gravitational wave detector we would
ultimately build identified all of the
major things that could go wrong all the
major noise sources as we say and
described ways of dealing with each one
an estimated what kind of accuracy you
can get after you dealt with them all a
tour de force and it was that was really
the beginning I think 72 for him and for
me of of they move the research that led
directly to Michael and so very quick
footnote LIGO for those who don't know
at all if you've not been paying
attention which is probably a tiny
fraction of the audience the laser
interferometric gravitational wave
observatory they found gravitational
waves but also for people who are not
physics experts let's talk a little bit
about the difference between being a
theorist such as yourself and being an
experimenter or an instrument builder
like Ray Weiss yeah well there's not a
very clean distinction between the two
but most physicists work essentially
entirely in theory developing models for
the universe or for things that happen
in the universe mathematical models
trying to understand the consequences of
experiments that have been done in the
past and the amplification implication
for things you might do in the future
but working with the mathematics and
with physical intuition to try to deduce
what's going on in the universe from
observation and and laws mathematical
laws of nature an experimenter designs
experiments builds apparatus to perform
them in order to investigate the laws of
nature and their predictions so Ray
Weiss a consummate experimenter who also
understands theory quite deeply but
focused his career on experiment
primarily he it was the primary designer
and inventor of these gravitational wave
detectors though the basic idea
underlying them had been also found
independently by other people even
earlier
it was the person who really built these
and made them happen I was a theorist
who set some vision for or we might
going be going but I also spend a lot of
my students a lot of time and energy
helping identify things who go wrong in
these gravity wave detectors and through
theoretical calculations with him with
the mathematics and physical
understanding identifying ways to deal
with them but I didn't go in and
actually build the apparatus right
that's right now you did that was a long
sentence that I think yeah sorry you
might have no no it was good except I
think that you you might have said most
physicists or theorists and I think you
know what I say most bizarre theories or
experience or experiment or
experimenters but but in my case and I
think this was essential when I was a
PhD student at Princeton I had made a
decision I was going to work in
relativity relativity was a wonderful
field I thought it was going to take off
it had been moribund for several decades
and I knew it could only me only take
off if it had some experimental
underpinnings and so I actually spent
much of a year working on experiment
just started to prepare myself so I
could interact with experimenters didn't
matter what kind of experiment I happen
to work in nuclear physics using a
machine called a cyclotron and then in
terms of research groups at Princeton I
had worked with in a theory research
group led by John Wheeler but I also
participated in the weekly group meeting
some experimental research group that
Ray Weiss was a postdoc in oh it was led
by deke a different professor and so so
I prepared myself for the possibility
they like Italy hood that I would be
able to work at the interface between
theory and experiment Dicky's famous
gravity group was partly responsible for
major research in the microwave
background precisely yeah yes yeah so we
might let's skip ahead and then what we
can come back but what was the final
product of all this thinking they
explained to us like oh what it is how
it looked
so LIGO is a set of instruments called
gravitational wave detectors or
gravitational wave interferometers that
are designed to detect these
gravitational waves coming from the
distant universe and extract the
information they carry so we could use
that information to learn about the
universe right
each of these instruments is something
that measures the stretching and
squeezing of space monitors the
stretching and squeezing of space
monitors the pattern of stretch and
squeeze what we have is we have four
mirrors each of them weighs about 40
kilograms a hundred pounds it doesn't
sound so bad yeah and they need to be
near perfect mirrors okay and they hang
from overhead supports by quartz fibers
I don't have any of those but you know
Amazon that's right that's right and you
put two mirrors along one arm of an L
and the other two along the other arm so
you have two arms that are perpendicular
with mirrors at each end of an arm and
when the gravitational wave comes along
it pushes the mirrors on one arm
together while especially the ones on
the other arm apart the amount of the
push and squeeze is the relevant thing
and for what we finally did detect it it
was 1/100 the diameter of a proton or
the nucleus of a hydrogen atom that
seems very small that is about roughly a
trillion times smaller than the
wavelength of the light that we use to
make the measurement and these mirrors
are in these mirrors how far apart they
are 4 kilometers apart is it underground
or just into there in tubes that you
should the laser didn't shoot the laser
down the tube and so you use laser beams
to monitor this stretching and squeezing
using
in this technique of interferometry but
the key thing is how the hell do you
measure motions mirrors that are four
kilometers apart when the motions are
about a trillion times smaller than the
wavelength of the light that you're
using how do you do it when that size is
a hundred times smaller than a proton in
a proton is a hundred thousand times
smaller than an atom and there you got
lots of individual atoms in the face of
this mirror so we're talking about ten
million times smaller than the
individual atoms that make up the face
of the mirror that are jiggling around
in the mirror all the time because
they're warm by a plethora of motion
that are also a huge so if someone said
you know can you find the location of
this proton to within this accuracy you
would say no that's impossible but
you're measuring the changes in location
due to the gravitational wave but you're
measuring the changes in location of
huge numbers of them you're measuring
actually the average position of all the
atoms in the mirror yeah and that's a
big part of why it's hard you have to
design your experiment is ratio to Sal
so that you're losing light that bounces
off the face of these off the jiggling
faces thermally jiggling faces in these
mirrors but you want the signal that's
put onto the light to only be influenced
by the motion of the center of a mirror
and not by the jiggles of the faces one
of the things you have to worry about is
just that any graduate student nearby
who sneezes is going to make the mirror
jiggle by much more than the
gravitational wave ring goodbye right
yeah so that that graduate student
better not be too close but there must
be like baffles in noise can yeah
there's huge numbers of things too to
deal with them and so that's why this
thing this whole experiment cost over a
billion US tax dollar dollars that's a
huge amount because there are so many
things that go wrong one way to describe
how many things can go wrong is
the number of data channels carrying
information out of the instrument than
out of the environment that each of
which could tell you something what's
going wrong is not a hundred not a
thousand not ten thousand about a
hundred thousand one hundred thousand
data channels telling you things that
monitoring things that might go wrong go
wrong and one day to channel carrying
gravitational wave information about the
pattern of stretch and squeeze that's
about yeah that's about right that's
about the challenge you face I mean how
much of this was clear in 1972 or how
much about we need to come to it no it
wasn't clear it was going to be that
complex but one of the best
experimenters I ever worked with
aside from Ray and Ronde River every
Caltech was later mayor Brzezinski in
Moscow he was absolutely superb became a
close personal friend and he was aside
from Joseph Weber the the other person
the second person to really jump into
this field and make a mark he was
enthusiastic about this but said it
wasn't for him because there were so
many things didn't go wrong it was very
dangerous to pursue this approach so he
recruits a pursuit a sec a simpler
approach through the 1970s and 80s he
came to visit Caltech and MIT where we
were working on Lyle in the late 1980s
looked at the progress looked at the
plans went home and shut down his whole
operation and joined LIGO he joined our
our effort but he he was superb and he
was just so very skeptical for about 15
years because of the complexity that
these instruments would have to have and
one of the worries was certainly like
what if the instrument worked perfectly
well but there's nothing out there
making large enough gravitational waves
to see right no it was a worry of the
community but it seemed clear to me not
with a hunt per hundred percent
confidence but up in the 95% confidence
level at least that we would have black
holes that orbit around each other and
merged
neutron stars that operated around each
other and merged and those already
became our primary sources that we were
planning to go after that dictated
things about the design of his
instruments already by about 1980 and
were you surprised at the exact thing
that you saw and was it what 2016 when
they saw the first event yeah 2015 15 it
was announced in 2016 that's right it
was precisely what I had expected except
the black holes were a little happier
than I expected
three times the mass of the Sun II yeah
I figured maybe 15 times the mass of the
Sun each but again this is what I had
been expecting since about 1980 we knew
enough about the universe that that
seemed like a pretty good bet then about
the universe and about these instruments
what a key part of that knowledge was
that heavier objects emit stronger waves
and so black holes if they were 15 times
heavier than the Sun that makes them ten
times heavier than a neutron star and
our primary sources we thought we're in
fact the things we have seen neutron
stars orbiting around each other
colliding black holes doing the same
thing with the black holes ten times
heavier you can see them ten times
farther that means the volume of the
universe you can see them through is 10
cubed the cubed for the three dimensions
of space right great or a thousand times
greater volume and it just seemed very
likely to me that there would that the
number of black holes it would be less
than neutron stars but it would be less
by a factor maybe a hundred not a
thousand and so that would be the first
thing we saw that is what we saw and
that's what I was aiming for is the most
likely thing to happen and these events
are quite rare sort of on a galaxy by
galaxy basis right I mean in our galaxy
how often do to 30 solar mass black
holes
I guess one in a million years okay
right but there's a lot of galaxies out
there that's how we learn right
precisely what have we learned about the
universe so far right by these
experimental
results well we've learned that black
holes do collide and merge that you do
they do form binary says we expected
similarly in the drive star forget we
truly didn't know that for sure we don't
know that for sure
to me one of the most interesting things
we have learned is the fact that when
two black holes collide you're colliding
two objects that aren't made from matter
they have no solid surfaces they have
nothing solid in them at all they're
made only from Warped space and warp
time and so when they collide and merge
they create a veritable storm in the
shape of space and the rate of flow of
time while the oscillating rate of flow
of time while the oscillating shape of
space like the surface of the ocean and
a huge storm out at sea and we didn't
know anything about storms in the fabric
of space and time even theoretically
until maybe three or four years ago and
up just a little bit before we
discovered gravitational waves from
these things the supercomputer
simulations solving Einstein's equations
on supercomputers begin to tell us about
these storms we have now seen the waves
from these storms the agreement between
the predictions of the simulations and
the observations is absolutely
remarkable and so for the first time now
we have both a theoretical understanding
and an observational and verification of
storms in the fabric of space and time
and I think that there's an aspect of
this story that maybe isn't as popularly
appreciated as as it could be we have
general relativity Einstein's theory of
space and time he gives us what we call
an equation Einstein's equation but in
some sense it's really multiple
equations talking to each other and it's
very complicated to solve and the you
can't get complicated interesting
solutions on pencil and paper you need a
computer and just a number of years ago
the idea of getting accurate real-world
useful numerical calculations from
Einstein's equations seemed very very
difficult maybe not feasible right
precisely
the actually the effort to create the
technology at the techniques for these
simulations for solving Einstein's
equations on computers lasted just as
long as our experimental effort lasted
half a century and in the early 2000s
well in the 1990s I was following that
effort with great interest because I was
expecting that the first things we would
see would be colliding black holes and
we wouldn't be able to say for sure what
you are seeing unless we had predictions
and predictions required these
simulations we would need the
predictions to compare with the
observations in order to deduce the
details and what the black holes were
doing the details of these storms and
the progress was painfully slow I was
chairing a Advisory Committee to the
collaboration of all the leading groups
in the world that were trying to do
these simulations and as the chair of
their advisory committee I was a guest
the slowness of progress I mean it was
very hard it wasn't they were done there
were the best people in the world that
was very very hard and so in fact I
personally left the LIGO project in
terms of day-to-day involvement in the
early 2000s in order to start a effort
at Caltech in doing these simulations in
collaboration with what I viewed as the
strongest group in the world a group of
Salta Kolski at Cornell in the early
2000s and it's not that I wrote code
computer code any more than I built the
apparatus relying go but at least I I
had some sense of where we needed to be
going what questions need to be asked
and what accuracies needed to be
achieved and so forth in these
simulations and so that's where I was
putting my effort when they can
gravitational waves were discovered that
I was not a major participant in the
endgame experimentally but we did make
amazing we the Royal we made quite
impressive progress over the last ten
years right yeah huge progress on the
simulations and huge progress
experimentally and the two came together
on that just the timescale that was
required and it was the marriage of the
simulations with the observation
that really led to our being able to
understand in depth what was being seen
so where does a 30 solar mass black hole
come from much less a pair of two 30
solar mass black holes right next to
each other ready to coalesce now you
tell me these were not expected they are
not expected of course in many maybe in
most cases when something unexpected is
seen 0-7 can come up with explanations
right and we have options right yeah
that's right come up with options and so
my personal the option that I think is
most likely to turn out to be true
is that you begin with smaller black
holes that form and sign what we call
globular clusters or big clusters of
stars and they sink to the bottom of the
cluster through gravitational
interactions with the smaller stars with
the weak less massive stars they sink to
the bottom they find each other they
collide and merge and then that merged
hole merges with another merge tall
right and you build up fairly quickly 2
to 30 solar mass black holes and these
are very different than the supermassive
black holes we have the Centers of
galaxies they are very different super
and so we get we're dealing with 30
solar mass black holes they once at the
center of our own galaxy is what about 4
million times the way mass of the Sun
one of the center of the Andromeda
galaxy in the nearest big galaxy to our
own is a little more like a hundred
million times the mass of the Sun so
they are completely different kinds of
beasts there any hope for someday seeing
those in gravitational waves yes I'm
sure we will see them will like I see
them
no no hasn't that's never prayer like go
through because of so the bigger the
black holes when they merge the slower
the oscillations of the waves as they
pass which means the longer the
wavelength of the waves and on the earth
when you get down to those oscillations
that are this slow now we're talking
about
ten minutes an hour ten hours noise on
the earth is horrendous in our time see
how this hopeless on earth you have to
get away from the earth and far away
from the earth in order and the noise on
the earth that comes from whether humans
and so forth and so that has to be done
out in interplanetary space and also you
would like to have your mirrors or deke
Logan of your mirrors roughly ten light
minutes apart right right that's right
how big is the earth in light second
well it's it's about a tenth of a light
second okay a few tenths about it a
tenth through a few hundredths of a
second and so we had this plan when I
was a kid there was this plane called
Lisa to put satellites in space that
would bounce lasers off of each other
and people then decide it was too
expensive but then you and your friends
discovered gravitational waves and
there's an effort to bring it back do
you have any idea how that's going well
I think the history is a little
different from that okay I think the
problem is that the NASA had a cost a
big cost overrun on the James Webb Space
Telescope and NASA pulled out of a
signed agreement with the European Space
Agency to do this mission yeah okay it
was not the first time that NASA pulled
out of agreements with the ESA Europeans
are getting accustomed to this the u.s.
is not a great partner for something
it's a result of the nature of our
political system yes not something that
NASA can control it's a result of their
hands awake they congressional election
system and the way things swing with new
administrations unfortunately for
science but anyway so so nasa pulled out
and then it was too expensive for the
europeans alone to do right so they
scaled the mission down they made it
less robust in a way that it was really
quite dangerous but in order to be able
to do it now as you say now the
gravitational waves have been seen by
but fast gravitational waves wrapping
the oscillating not the slow ones that
Lisa would see now that's been seen and
the Europeans have flown a test
apparatus that verifies that the most
serious sources of noise that had been
identified are under control we expect
Lisa to be on a fast track
very likely with NASA rejoining as a
junior partner not an equal partner well
and again yeah that's what happens and
in parallel the Chinese are pushing very
hard to do this to do a simpler analog
to Lisa faster so they're the first ones
to cease and grab these gravitational
waves in space that can often be very
very useful I mean let's do a quick
dirty thing just to see the scope of the
land and then go back and do it right
yeah yeah and this is you know one of
the things again we take for granted but
it's worth emphasizing is here's Albert
Einstein a hundred years ago almost a
little bit over a hundred years ago you
know from very you know thought
experimenting
kind of inputs right like there was no
data that said oh you have to throw out
Newtonian gravity both roughly speaking
and but he had principles he knew about
special relativity he knew about other
things that he wanted to be true the
principle equivalence and he came up
with general relativity which both you
and I have written textbooks about by
the way we're competitors in that way
well hardly competitors my textbook was
written decades before your excellency
you sold a lot more copies than I did
yeah we don't sell today nearly what you
sell I think though they're making
younger ones I'm sure but and he was
right and and in some sense not only was
he right about the predictions for the
experiments which it took us like you
say years to figure out but the feature
the fact that space-time is curved and
and that curvature is gravity we're
still learning about what that really
means at a deep level is that fair to
say yes I think that's very fair to
saying what do you think is the future
of what what we need to learn about
space-time and general relativity even
though we have the equation written down
well that's far the key thing recent
thing and the thing
that excites me for the next five years
maybe a little longer is understanding
these storms in the shape of space and
time so for example we've come to
understand first through computer
simulations and then understanding it in
the equations directly that's sticking
out of each spinning black hole is a
twisting vortex of space that okay it
you it's very much like the twist of a
tornado so two tornadoes taking out a
black hole one of them at the North Pole
of the black hole it has a
counterclockwise twist of space South
Pole a clockwise twist of space and
these vortices when you have two black
holes collide and merge you wind up then
with four vortices sticking out of a
pair of the merged back hole plus two
more vortices that you were created by
the orbital angular momentum so you can
have as many as six vortices sticking
out black holes don't like to have any
more than two vortices and so these
vortices have to fight with each other
in some manner and do a shakedown to two
part of the C's so there's a very
interesting behavior of empty space yeah
yeah I mean we had no idea about this
until we saw so that some of this in
simulations and then started thinking
about it theoretically so these black
holes are spinning very rapidly we say
those words but really just like you
said it's empty space it's as if it were
spinning very rapidly right so if I fall
into one of these black holes can I
travel across the universe uh probably
not
certainly not almost well how would I
then traveled across the universe if I
was do that I think this is a leading
question because I know you know a
famous colleague of yours back in the
day asked a similar question yeah yeah
well it was a guy a close friend Carl
Sagan yeah I had written a novel called
contact
well he's originally written the
screenplay and then he turned it into a
novel and it's like getting made into a
movie very fast
why would anyone make a movie like that
any anyway so he wanted his heroin who
became Jodie Foster to travel through a
black hole to the vicinity of the star
Vega and and so he sent me the page
proofs of his book he was already the
point rate nearly rated love time yeah I
know and said you know I might realize I
might be in trouble can you help me and
I read them driving up to see I think
was driving up and see my daughter
graduate from Santa for UC Santa Cruz
okay grab them in the car and and fired
off a response and said well you can't
do it with black holes she's gonna die
[Music]
and so you want to use a wormhole and a
hypothetical object that is somewhat
similar to a black hole in the sense
that it is it has a spherical mouth that
is sort of like the horizon of a black
hole except you can travel two ways
through this mouth you can travel in and
back out and you go through it and it
leads to another place in the universe
and I so just so we're not in getting
trouble with the physics police here
black holes really exist wormholes not
only are hypothetical but is it I mean
what are the chances that wormholes
exist in the real world I think the
chances that they exist naturally are
exceedingly small the chances that they
can be made by an artificial
civilization are bigger but still small
and if they get made by an advanced
civilization they probably implode
before you can travel through them the
chances that the civilization can
stabilize them so you can travel through
again are small but not zero and so the
issue is that motivated by Carl Sagan's
question and by my suggesting that he
used wormholes and in what became the
movie contact I and other of my
physicist colleagues started working
hard
try to understand do the laws of physics
allow them and yeah it was obvious
already from the beginning that they
would unless you did something very
strange with them they would have the
self-destruct just they would implode
and sorting trying to sort that out and
to my surprise we couldn't get it sorted
out fully but all that the work that has
been done points rather strongly to a
conclusion that probably they can't
exist and if they can't exist they very
probably can't exist naturally yeah so
this was circa late eighties early 90s
so their work on this continues to do
today but a small level the bulk of the
research on this was done late 80s early
to mid 90s and but it it still continues
because the answer isn't in right we
still don't know so Carl Sagan wants to
let Ellie Arroway travel across the
galaxy you say it should be a wormhole
not a black hole and then you realize
you know wormholes were again coined by
John Wheeler is that true that phrase so
I find by John Wheeler the concept
actually goes back to Hermann vile about
1922
I dunno yeah I would have given Einstein
credit but yeah so so it was conceived
perhaps independently by Einstein and
his colleague rose and I Stein and Rosen
in in 36 but you cofac you back and you
find it in hermann violin route in 1922
and but it was John Wheeler who really
pushed hard to understand these
initially because he had intuition which
may have been right that on very small
scales what we call the Planck length
the scale where space and time as we
know them must become probabilistic they
fluctuate like anything in the universe
fluctuates due to quantum physics on
those very small scales John Wheeler
argued that there you would likely find
a froth of fluctuating wormholes right
okay so that was his
central focus there's this rough problem
maybe this is getting a little bit too
technical but I can't resist so Einstein
gives us this equation for general
relativity Einstein's equation and we
might want to say well why can't you
just solve the equation and part of the
problem is there's a left hand side
which says space-time is curved and
there's a right hand side which says
there's stuff in the universe matter and
energy and so forth causing space-time
to curve and the left hand side with the
curvature is very pretty and
understandable and the right hand side
with stuff is kind of a mess is that
about why we don't understand wormholes
very well well that's it maybe a piece
of it that's a piece of it because
although wormholes are things that are
made from warp space-time without matter
if you have them made from warp
space-time without matter then they
self-destruct right so you have to put
some kind of matter in them to hold them
open and that's where it becomes tough
that's where the rest of physics becomes
and that's all a messy terrible thing
the other issue and that was this was
the issue for a wheeler is that when you
get down to these very tiny length
scales associated with quantum effects
that there you don't even know the
correct laws of physics at all well and
so then you have to start speculating
and that's where he came I think some
pretty plausible arguments that you
would have this quantum foam of
fluctuating wormholes but they're the
problem is you don't understand the laws
of physics for a big wormhole you don't
understand the matter well enough to be
sure that whether you can hold the room
all open with it but if you have a big
wormhole and you can use it to travel
across the galaxy very quickly don't you
worry because special relativity says I
can't go faster than the speed of light
it's like going backward in time come on
the speed of light we all know yeah but
not locally right and so let's be more
precise yeah I think so
so the universe is expanding as we know
your cosmology and understand this far
better than I do and the most distant
part of the universe is moving away from
us faster than the speed of light so we
can't see it because they can't get to
us from it but it's it's doing it
and so is what the speed limit really
says is that if you have two objects
that are close enough to each other that
there's no significant warping of space
and time between them then they can't
move fashion the speed of light with
respect to each other but when you've
got a wormhole you've got lots of War
paper space and time and all bets are
off right seeking just and ever since
well I don't know if contact was the
first movie to use wormholes do you
think so across the and now every movie
does it so yeah it's dark like the
button everybody else but then I don't
know whether it was you or your
collaborators but you began to realize
that if you can travel across great
distances of space maybe you can also go
backward in time no you know so they so
that was me in this case I mean other
people had working in relativity had
seen other ways that you might be able
to go backwards in time this was just
one more way right but one that was
became particularly popular maybe
because of contact if you were there I
would say that it was you know you could
imagine building it like a lot of the
other ways to build time machines
started by saying imagine you have an
infinitely long cylinder right at least
the wormhole that's contained in some
regions and once you have a wormhole
once you have a worm oh yeah so with a
couple of my students Mark Mark Morris
Mike Morris and Andover yurt Seaver I
worked out how you would if you had
aroma ha how you would use it to it make
a time machine it's fairly simple you
just take one mouth and I put my wife in
one mouth she carries that mouth out
through the universe and her spaceship
and comes back at high speed and time
for her slows down as seen in the
external universe I said on earth it
doesn't slow down but is seen through
the wormhole our clocks run at the same
rate so you begin the clocks always
running at the same rate hers and mine
as seeing through the wormhole when she
comes back
she's very young and I'm very old as
seen through the exterior as seen
through the interior of the wormhole
we're the same age and so there's
something crazy going on the craziness
is that you would created a time machine
right so that so that was fairly simple
and fairly obvious but I think yes right
this was something that if you had a
wormhole you could actually make it and
so then the question became what did the
laws of physics say about this could you
really do it and there comes in that the
key thing that things if you're an
engineer in a very advanced civilization
and you can do anything that is allowed
by the laws of physics you've got to
look at more than the laws of relativity
this loss of relativity say yeah sure
you can make a time machine yeah you've
also got to look at the laws of quantum
physics and the behavior of matter
there's always going to be some matter
present because we're quantum physics
it's always at least a little bit of
fluctuating matter present and so you
then asked okay now you've got a
wormhole you turn into a time machine
relativity allowed it what did quantum
physics do what did it say and the
answer is that quantum physics says with
high probability that the wormhole is
going to self-destruct at the moment you
turn it into a soft time machine it
seems like from various different
perspectives the universe is kind of
reluctant to let you build a time
machine it does seem that way do you
would it bother you if we could build
the time machine I mean there are
logical paradoxes involved right and
anything that says the laws of nature
are different than your expect it's
wonderful you're gonna learn wonderful
thing is that how you knew and there are
these other needs to think about
gravitational so yes so then you
immediately do worry about paradoxes and
so that's what I did with again with
students and colleagues and so we asked
ourselves okay suppose you do have a
wormhole you did turn it into a time
machine successful
it didn't self-destruct in the process
then how do you deal with these
paradoxes how does nature deal with
these paradoxes and so what we did was
we hit hey
well like calling my dear colleague of
mine in yours Joe polchinski who just
passed away sadly fairly recently a
really great theoretical physicist
physicist he had been a student of mine
years ago decades ago and Joe has sent
me and a female I think it was an email
maybe was a letter in those days this is
about not don't I got an email dated
yeah and he said well here's a little
thought experiment you you send the
billiard ball into a a-1 wormhole mouth
and it comes back out before of the
other mouth before it went in it hits
itself and prevents itself from going in
how do you solve that paradox so we
called this polchinski paradox and so
together with some students I worked out
how what does nature say about function
sees paradox we found that there are
multiple ways that nature can get out of
it okay you the beater ball goes in it
gets hit a very gentle blow by itself on
his way in so it goes in it comes out on
a slightly different trajectory than it
was supposed to and hits itself a Jarett
very gentle dwell and so everything is
alright but there are a number of
general ways it can do through these
gentle blows and so you wind up with
more than one solution the laws of
physics instead of just one solution
where you thought there were none you
thought I did it
there's no no way no answer to what
happens to the billiard ball when it
goes in because you've got a paradox
that first time you say the bigger ball
goes in it comes back out it hits itself
and prevents its from cell phone going
in that's the trajectory and then you
find a trajectory where it's modified
itself and then you find another one and
then
and in the laws of classical physics
there had not ought to be multiple
solutions when you pull this initial
conditions there should not be multiple
answers and so then you go to quantum
physics yet you ask what this quantum
physics say and so it becomes a very
interesting game and actually trying to
figure out how does nature get out of
this and this much easier to deal with
this with billiard balls than with human
beings who go back in time trying to
kill their grandparents that's the
fourth common thing but yojo is a good
physicist I love the simple physics
problem
so it's interesting because on basic
features of sort of logical consistency
we would not want to have a true paradox
where two incompatible things happened
and you're saying that it seems that at
least at the classical level what nature
gives up on is not logical consistency
but predictability there's more than one
possible way out but that then we we pay
attention to the fact that the world is
really fundamentally quantum at the
bottom and so where you have these
multiple solutions classically you go in
and analyze some quantum mechanically
uh-huh and what is you and I would call
it wkb approximation so you see that the
quantum physics probably has a solution
to get around this and there's probably
one unique solution so so my bottom line
with with this and my problem is that I
was just in deep into this and and felt
like I was making some progress in
understanding how you would deal with
paradoxes when LIGO got funded and I
said do I spend my rest of my life
career now working hard on making
gravitational waves of success or do I
think about time travel paradoxes I love
time travel but you made the right
choice but when you mentioned quantum
mechanics they're just just because I
know probably some people know a little
bit about the idea of branching the
universe off because you have a time
machine in creating a new timeline and
that's not what you're talking about
right it's not at all what you're
talking you're just using quantum
mechanics to find the one consistent
most probable trajectory so they don't
actually happen
so what you really want to do and is
ask how you formulated quantum mechanics
and in the presence of a time machine
right and in fact there is a way to do
it and it's using a formulation of
quantum mechanics due to our dear friend
richard fineman yeah and but a
generalization of hymens ideas dude in
his colleague murray gell-mann right and
jim Harlan so so the tools are there
very Caltech II feel very Caltech you
feel that's right well it with Heartland
say Caltech in Santa Barbara but the
tools are there was an immigrant student
at Caltech back in the day he was Murray
gell-mann rad student and child leaders
undergraduate postdoc but anyway so so I
say you can formulate quantum mechanics
in a way that handles all this and the
presence of : clothing of what we call a
closed timelike in the press is for a
time machine but for me the beautiful
thing about this is that once you've
done that you discover that information
gets lost right
this is don't like this and physicists
don't like this don't like this but I
think it's quite wonderful that anyway
they say and so then you get caught up
in the so-called information loss
paradox and a view of this that that I
have that's kind conic plastic that
differs from that of the majority of
physicists but it's a good little lesson
about how you know you're fooling around
in some sense right like you weren't
trying to build a time machine you were
inspired by a question from Carl Sagan
but it needs you just some maybe
interesting insights into questions
people really care about precisely since
how I came to appreciate that in areas
where you're dealing with physics beyond
where we can actually do experiments
today someday we will but not today
thought experiments like these simple
thought experiments like what happens to
billiard balls if they collide throw a
wormhole that has a time machine built
into it that simple thought experiments
can sometimes take pretty deeply into
the laws of nature and nevertheless I
remember a footnote or the
acknowledgments one of your papers
saying that the National Science
Foundation wouldn't let
you to work on this anymore that was a
half tongue-in-cheek yeah only half so
the story is that I was working on this
in parallel with gearing up to build
LIGO and we had our major funding for
LIGO in the end 1.1 billion dollars for
a lie ago coming from the National
Science Foundation and I had a
conversation about this research with
Richard Isaac's and a superb a director
of a and program director for our field
that in a self person who I regard the
Ray Weiss and very bearish and I regard
as the as really our collaborator in
Washington to mate who really made this
happen anyway so Isaacson said to me you
don't want to screw things up for LIGO
if some congressman comes in and starts
hacking at you for working on time
machines and maybe you can find finding
elsewhere for that that work just to
keep yourself safe from from being
attacked by some it sounds like good
advice very good advice but I also
tweaked back yeah Richard I think so
what in these acknowledgments this work
was not supported by the national
science not was instead it was supported
by the Richard chase Fineman Research
Fund at Caltech Tolman told mr. Tollman
it was the Tollman funds that's right
and that's expansion point it was okay I
know these were these were this was in
the 90s so I became the Fineman
professor 91 yeah I don't I think it was
Fineman fun sense okay that could be I
don't think it was fine with on this
field so but there's another spin-off of
this fortuitous conversation you have
with Carl Sagan was that you got
interested in the phenomenon of
Hollywood making science fiction movies
right yeah and is it is it exactly right
or maybe you can correct me like you
were not perfectly happy without the
movie version of contact
yeah so that's right so George Miller
was the original director of contact and
he was working very hard to perfect the
last the tail end of the movie involving
wormholes and the ultimate de Newland at
the end of the movie in the right and he
got canned by the studio for taking too
long
Hollywood yep yep and so they brought in
Zemeckis and with that order you
finished things off you don't diddle any
longer with a screenplay you finish
things off and we want to get into
production and so he did and basically
all the efforts that were being put into
it really perfecting the last part of
the movie and went down the tubes and so
I was disappointed in that so did that
inspire you to say someday I'll do it
right no no no I never had any intention
any intention to do that but yeah it was
always in the back of my mind but the I
got into this simply because it Linda
opes who had been Carl's partner in
Hollywood on contact a movie producer
great movie producer and she called me
up one day in 2004 and said would you
like to brainstorm with me for a science
fiction movie okay and that's what led
to interstellar that's what led bender
stellar but it was I had no plan to do
that so we just I mean we have Hollywood
people in the podcast so we don't need
to you know rehearse the entire process
but how do you go from brainstorming to
seeing your name up there as an
executive producer oh that that happens
by having a very good attorney so Linda
said to me once we brainstormed and she
had brought on a studio which bought an
option to make the movie from the
treatment that she and I had created
through brainstorming treatments just a
description of a story and in our case
of science in bed
in the story so she brought in a studio
and she said you have to negotiate with
the studio you can't do it yourself you
have to have an attorney okay so with
the help of a Caltech president who went
to a member of the Board of Trustees who
was well-connected in Hollywood I got a
great attorney different good and no
people in high places and Ken negotiated
and got me an executive producer credit
and off the bat
based on the brainstorming that we had
done initially and on the expectation
that I would stick with the project all
the way through and would be the lead
science advisor and make and realize the
vision that Linda and I had formulated
of a film with science embedded deeply
into it from the outset and what
happened what was the first step was it
getting the director or the screenwriter
or so then brought on it well the story
is that Linda brought on Steven
Spielberg to direct it and the two of
them were both with Paramount at the
time and so that then they brought on
paramount Steven then was the director
through the early creative phase on
making the movie the early creative
phase lasted for a few years they
brought on Jonathan Nolan or Jonah as
he's known to his friends to write the
screenplay Jonah had written a couple of
screenplays previously with his brother
Christopher Nolan but that was his the
extent of his experience in Hollywood
since then he has created person of
interest in West world and West world
and yet he's doing okay he's going on
West world with his wife at least a joy
right and so but he he was really pretty
green and young at the time but superb
and wonderful to work with so so he went
through three drafts of the screenplay
and then as Steven always carries more
movies in the creative phase than he can
possibly make and he came to crunch time
came and he was going to make Lincoln
okay art is going to make
interesting interstellar and I don't
know he may have had other choices as
well but he did make the choice to make
Lincoln he certainly has like over a
dozen movies and development as writing
so that was his choice and Christopher
Nolan being Jonathan's brother had said
to Linda before Steven dropped out she
he had said if Steven drops out I would
be interested in considering making this
movie pretty good backup possibility
just ahead you know and you know and so
when Steven dropped out yeah
then Linda and paramount started to try
to negotiate with Chris Chris said no I
won't negotiate until after my next
movie comes out and has been out for
maybe six months then he'll negotiate
he's the opposite right this is one
thing he doesn't one thing at a time he
doesn't even make a decision about the
next thing he's going to do until the
previous movie has been out for a few
months he sees how it's been done he's
gone through all of the the publicity on
it and so forth and and then he starts
thinking seriously about what he'll not
do next so we waited for two and a half
years well he did Batman The Dark Knight
Rises right and then after a few months
after that came out he negotiated
seriously with the Paramount he had by
then Linda had had a divorce with
paramount acid Steven and Chris was not
about ready to work with paramount okay
so Chris said I only work with with
Warner Brothers and so and none of your
physics education had prepared you for
any of this but fortunately I had a
great attorney
I had a great partner and Linda knows
her she she knows the ropes and ken
knows those so I just sat back and
waited and got briefed by phone and
email from time to time and so anyway
it was obvious that Chris was the person
who should make this movie obvious to
everybody and so paramount negotiated
with Warner Brothers that wormer others
would have the rights all the foreign
rights to this movie paramount would
have the domestic US rights and they
would do it jointly but the production
would be in the hands of Warner Brothers
because that's where Chris works what's
this home okay and it as you say this is
not part of part of my training so I
watched this all a wonderful education
really yeah and speaking of Education
you figured out you had some good
science projects come out of the
attempts to get the science right in the
movie yeah yeah and so on yeah so I very
much enjoyed working well I enjoyed
brainstorming with the Nolan brothers I
enjoyed my interactions with the actors
and particularly with the computer
graphics team double- limited in London
led by Paul Franklin who was one of the
founders and leaders of double- and
together then at Chris Christopher
Nolan's request enthusiastic request
which I was expecting he wanted
everything that involved visualizations
of black holes and wormholes and
Astrophysical objects to be done as
accurately as possible through computer
simulations and solving the propagates
through the equation for propagation of
light from the source of the light
through the environment to an IMAX
camera through the optics of the IMAX
cameras with all of the vagaries of the
objects of the IMAX camera to the film
at the end and and so that was how it
was done and I provided the equations
for the propagation of the light to
Oliver James who was the chief scientist
at double- and he programmed the
equations and the artists there created
the images of the sources of the light
and it all came together quite
beautifully and I remember if I remember
correctly you saying that not all
science and movie might be plausible but
it's absolutely compatible with what we
currently know
not everything almost everything almost
everything well that's the agreement
between Chris Renault under me from the
outset it was I told him I wanted
everything to be compatible to laws of
nature and he said I'm enthusiastic to
do that as long as it doesn't get in the
way of making a great movie which is
fairly
génifique affair and he was afraid
however I would play the role of science
police right and and I was afraid he
wouldn't respect to science and within a
few hours of brainstorming together it
became obvious that we were on the same
wavelength that we could work together
as beautifully as I had worked with his
brother on the screenplay and it became
a marvelous collaboration there did come
one point when we had had these
wonderful images of the wormhole and of
the spacecraft traveling around and
through around the wormhole and then
they had to make the computer graphics
for the trip through the wormhole and I
got a telephone call from uh from
Christopher Nolan said Kip would you
come over to my house we got a problem
okay we I went over and he said we've
tried various sizes and shapes of
wormholes this is what they trip through
the wormhole looks like with this shape
and size the world that's what it looks
like there's another one none of them
are very exciting they're all pretty
dull and because they would be and so he
said so he says and so what do we do I
said you use creative license that's the
one place where there was a substantial
departure from what things would really
be like everywhere else there were a
number of other places with little
departures yeah if you want to know all
of the places that I was aware of at the
time the movie came out there were a few
I missed where there were little little
glitches with regard to laws of physics
you go to my book the science of
interstellar first you buy the book the
same time and yeah
anyway you go to the subject index but
you look up a person in the subject
index
you look up Christopher Nolan and then
under Christopher Nolan in the subject
index you see all of the compromises
that he made with a science in order to
make a great movie
your conscience is clean you know you
well it's also a with most books that
I've written over my career there are
little gems like this hit yeah Adam
that's a good thing and and you if you
may find them if you're clever in the in
an index or you may be told the authors
have to keep themselves entertained
those everybody else so do you have
another movie and the idea pot yeah so
Stephen Hawking and Linda hopes and I
wrote the treatment for and follow-on
movie several years ago before Stephen
passed away and we're very enthusiastic
about the movie again a science fiction
movie again with science real science
and built into it we were aware as well
so with this movie then we went through
the same process hey Linda identified
the studio we sold an option well she
and my lawyer buyer Ken's Efrain and his
team sold an option to make the movie
from our treatment to a studio the
studio hired the screenwriter that we
wanted they have now been offer out to
the director we want okay and it may go
forward but I'm not allowed to say
anything no and that's probably more
than I have a lot it's not even asking
but probably that much is on IMDB
already right like so much of us out now
you so you've enjoyed the process I've
enjoyed the process very much
Arianna shed and I should say with
interstellar the Nolan Brothers changed
the story so so much there it wasn't
Linda's in my story at all we didn't
even in the way things work in Hollywood
if you've written the story for a movie
then you go and you ask the
screenwriters guild that you want a
credit for story by we didn't even ask
her incredible first story by because
they had changed the story in very
positive ways we're in the Suzy
ask you about the changes they had made
so this wound up is the Nolan's movie
but with a science that came from Linda
and me and then additional science from
the brainstorming with an Allman
Brothers in this second movie so far
it's falling pretty closely the story
that we began with in the dream it's
amazing it may be Steven and I and Linda
will get credit for story I will see
well Kip Laura I think that one thing
everyone who's listened to the podcast
will be able to say is you've you've
been very successful you've had a great
life I've had great fun I've had a great
fun yeah and I love the variety of it we
didn't even get into the Mary's books
that you've written but you know great
science a little bit of fun living here
in LA it's been a great conversation
thanks so much being on podcast thank
you
[Music]